en 2000 la téléphonie explose en france
les opérateurs installent des milliers
d'antennes relais pour acheminer les
communications pas trop pas trop bail
aux dominés en fait dominer le bnd zone
demandé par l'opérateur
les opérateurs ont eu elles seules
obligations à respecter limiter la
puissance des émissions de
radiofréquences dont le seuil a été
établi par le parlement européen en 1999
niveau maximum auquel on peut mesurer ce
champ est de 41 volts par mètre malgré
cette limitation de plus en plus de
riverains d'antennes ce plein et
d'effets indésirables
la notion d' électrosensibilité fait son
apparition
deux mois après ça a été les maux de
tête qui ont commencé ça a été les
palpitations
ça a été des acouphènes des symptômes
ignoré par les opérateurs
aujourd'hui aucune étude publiée ne nous
fait penser que nous sommes dans une
situation où il pourrait y avoir un
risque sanitaire
en mars 2001 un décret basé sur une
étude recommande d'appliquer le principe
de précaution
conséquence l'installation des antennes
à moins de 100 mètres des sites
sensibles comme les hôpitaux ou des
écoles est interdite
ce texte permet à ses parents d'élèves
de faire retirer l'antenne installée sur
leur école aujourd'hui il faut que
chaque politique prenne ses
responsabilités de telle sorte à ce que
ça ne devienne pas l'histoire du sang
contaminé ça ne devienne pas l'histoire
de l'amiante ça devienne pas l'histoire
du ciment malgré ce principe de
précaution le nombre de personnes se
plaignant d' électrosensibilité
progresse en 2003 un rapport de l'agencé
française de sécurité sanitaire et
environnementale
on établit toujours aucun lien entre
électrosensibilité et on t'aime outre
les travaux internationaux publiés
montrent qu'il n'y a aucun danger avec
les antennes relais aucun danger
pourtant les procédures judiciaires se
poursuivre en 2009 le ministère de la
santé organise un grenelle des ondes
mais une fois de plus les associations
sont déçus par ces conclusions
aujourd'hui les opérateurs les pouvoirs
publics sont les scientifiques sont dans
l'incapacité de dire que les antennes
relais sont inoffensives donc bien
puisqu'on ne sait pas on va dans les
tribunaux une étude de mars 2018 de
l'ansès recoller celles existantes en
france de six cent mille à six millions
de personnes électrosensibles sans
toutefois établir des relations avec les
antennes relais le débat sur la nocivité
des ondes électromagnétiques est loin
d'être terminée surtout avec le
développement prochain de la 5g
[Musique]